what do you think's gonna happen through
the end of the year like a price
prediction for bitcoin i said it january
1st 250. so i have to stick with it so
you think we're gonna hit 250. what's
the logic behind getting into 250 000
bitcoin by the end of the year uh so
statistically speaking uh
if you look at the growth of every bull
market 2013 2017 four years later here
we are after having uh the statistically
where we will go is somewhere 230 250 if
we follow that same path
also you have other models you have the
s2f model basically in line you have
people who use the uh pure multiple to
show when there's a time to perfect time
to buy which was during the pandemic of
2020 right now we're on the path to
where it'll be around 210 based on that
model so it just kind of lines up to go
that way
and i think um also quarter four
wall street gets those bonuses people
start uh looking to
reduce their tax uh their tax liability
so they put it into assets and since
bitcoin is an asset that usually people
fomo into we hit 70 80k hey man you
already know what happens after that
because i mean if we really i mean just
psychologically thinking if we hit 100k
and it zooms from there there's gonna be
so many people that say i'm i cannot
miss this i can't i mean we hit 100 and
then all of a sudden it's 120 140 people
oh my god what just happened i got to
buy it that's why i think uh we'll have
the momentum to go past 200. so once
that starts to happen we hit all-time
high then we go past 100 go past 150. is
it just like a blow off top or you think
we come back down on the other side and
get another like 70 80 drawdown at some
point yeah i think we we have that uh i
don't know if it'll be 78 but i do think
the bear markets would be shorter only
because
the 2017 bear market after it happened
was a lot of retail traders this time is
more institutional they're constantly
buying you think michael sailor's not
gonna be buying every dip in the bear
market do you think el salvador is not
buying every dip other countries during
that bear market are not gonna be buying
every dip leading up to 2024 which is
the next happening after that i just
think it's it's over from there i don't
think a regular person's gonna be able
to buy one bitcoin after 2024 so yeah i
definitely see uh blow off top i i think
there'll be some sort of event that
happens that causes it not sure what
that will be but our government is is
dumb enough to do so they've been
they've showed their stupidity over the
last year to push people to alternative
currencies like bitcoin so
it should be fun definitely so if we go
to 250 000 do you think that not only
the retail investors who definitely
drive uh through fomo um but do you
think a lot of institutions start to
follow in once we get past like 150k
yeah because if we get to that point i
believe we'll be at a five trillion
dollar market gap somewhere in there
that's about half of golds or on the way
to golds
can't ignore that i mean at that point
it's sort of uh you'll be left in the
desk and one thing people don't know
about institutional investors is most of
them don't have a original thought in
their mind they all copy each other so
as soon as the one guy gets rich who was
uh you know terrible before he's like
well i should be doing it too that's
that's how it starts and i think we're
seeing that now i mean we're seeing a
lot of i think even larry fink he didn't
say bitcoin was bad he didn't say it was
good either but he sort of i think he's
sitting there thinking like okay well we
have trillions of dollars uh aum so why
not like why wouldn't we buy more so i
think that thought is starting to
permeate and uh we'll see some something
fun in the future also etf might be
coming uh people have been saying oh
what if they approve etf next week i
think the floodgates will be open at
that point do you think the ecf's gonna
happen maybe but who cares
like i think people put too much into
all of these uh uh institutional uh
products that got us where we are now
all they do is really just put us back
where you are but it does let a lot of
money enter into the space so it is it
is getting you know it's in that
positive positive